everyone can now get a free wall hack in
CS2 you want to something cool well I'm
going to do it
[Music]
anyway you have got to be kidding me the
Cs Community has discovered that a
pretty common Nidia filter just straight
up lets you see people through smokes
look at
this oh my God I'm not shooting I'm not
I'm not shooting I'm not shooting for
the uninitiated the point of smokes in
CS is to hide you from your opponents
now just turn on a couple of filters on
the Nvidia overlay maybe even put in a
hotkey and poof goes down filter on
suck people have expressed their
disappointment that valve let this slip
through the cracks but come on are we
really surprised no not really